hi guys hello my name's Gerry Cheevers
and I am Cody Meltzer and this is Tamra
Jessa and Cody also just saw two as well
we just saw transformers five and it was
not transformative I have only seen one
in two because I I'll admit it I'm
obsessed and sure enough that's true she
was obsessed with Shia LaBeouf I had
only seen the first one uh as as much as
you can see it like it still makes no
real sense and the whole second half of
the movie is just flashes of CGI it
feels but you saw the movie yeah I
understand why this franchise started
off strong sure 100%
there's the nostalgia and they look
well-made and I still have questions
about Optimus Prime and conservation of
mass and matter cuz like if you look it
off in his prime and then you look at
truck prime truck prime just seems like
he's made of less stuff than robot
Optimus Prime I haven't seen a 3 or 4
but it just seems like it's the same
thing every time it seems like it's like
alright here we go
world is in trouble Optimus Prime is
gonna save them something weird happens
and then they go but it's like it's like
2 hours too long this one had like the
exact same actress it just wasn't Megan
Fox it was Megan Fox hunt is what I
called her she's British Megan posh she
looked just like Megan Fox and same kind
of inserted like shoehorn and romance
that was just really poorly written
everything was everything was shoehorned
in and poorly written and not even in a
fun way
yes like come on like look look I
documented on this channel love The Fast
and the Furious franchise I love that
fridge I bought it a lot of blu-ray
and so even the bad parts I was like
fine at least it's fun yeah this isn't
that like a movie with this many
explosions shouldn't be this hard to
keep my interest I have never seen so
much get rushed in such a long movie
it's over it's well over two hours with
two and a half hours this movie is so
bad that former sir Tony Hopkins cannot
save it whoever wrote the dialogue for
this movie has never heard a person talk
outside of an action movie and more ways
than just action sequences and like the
romance he winces like we've seen action
films that have good comedy comedy was
so lazy in this I asked you after if it
was Matt Damon or it was Mark Wahlberg
but I still don't know it was Mark
Wahlberg Russell just date because we
don't get it looks fine I guess but it's
three hours of like pretty cgi so it's
not impressive it's not enough to be
like well that was fine too the
cinematography this is the writing not
great the comedy falls flat the romance
awful I mean it was nice of them to get
every single actor in the world for this
movie because there there were I don't
know upwards of a thousand characters
introduced in this film at one point
they realize that they had so many that
they just started naming robots and
putting their names on the screen that
was a thing that happened in the movie
when they did the trade and Megatron's
naming robots he wants action wasn't uh
super impressive I feel like there
wasn't anything that I was all that was
really cool looking it was just all like
blah like Michael Bay action and again I
haven't seen three or four I don't know
if it would have tied things in better I
tweeted that we were at the movie and it
got 68 responses so far and all but one
were like nope you don't need to see the
other two it doesn't matter who cares
it's all the same and I'm just objective
but I really don't imagine that it would
have helped very much having backstory
wouldn't change how muddled everything
happening in this movie is like Michael
Bay's entire concept of related
relationships is through action figures
that he has matched together as a child
and continues to do so to this day I
don't imagine that you're going to agree
with me on this but I did find where
they were going with the doric things
the King Arthur and and the round table
and all of that I found that compelling
but it didn't reach the point of being
compelling I thought it could have been
really cool I really enjoy that kind of
stuff that like division code where
they're like you're the only defendant
who can use the sword staff it's like
that's cool but I didn't ever get to a
point where they needed any of that
stuff from the past it was just a lazy
way for them to write it in there's one
thing so the new Megan Fox is like the
one dissent agrees staff and then Mark
Wahlberg is the chosen one who the alien
robot gives like ancient alien as a ten
referred to them as the ancient aliens
of the theater and I was like oh man
there's a lot of conspiracy theories now
that would have been so much better but
if I would have much preferred an
ancient aliens movie even give ancient
aliens Gibson's medallion and then
you've got this like alien like metal on
him the whole time and he that whole
scenery shirtless and they're like I was
going down your pants yeah which was
annoying but the point is like the this
is supposed he's supposed to be the
warrior that that is the chosen warrior
and it's literally only used one time in
the movie other than the ploy for it
going down his pants in it to be like a
sexy awkward moment like they're like oh
so dumb one time is when he's defending
Optimus Prime and he raises up a sword
and blocks it doesn't even like spikes
anybody he just blocked the blow and
that's literally the one time he's used
that thing and it's like a giant part of
the film is like that's the whole
beginning she gets this like metal thing
up and it's just why didn't they use
that they didn't go far enough with
certain things like they went way too
far with other things
and it just the story was so muddled
they didn't know what they were doing no
everything's rushed I mean everything is
rushed and resolved quickly optimus
prime becomes evil quickly and then stop
being evil quickly every and then other
element I mean that's not a spoiler
because it's in the trailer but like
every element the you know the evil is
defeated quickly and suddenly this is
done quickly and suddenly these
characters become best friends quickly
and suddenly and these people fall in
love with each other quickly and
suddenly also they specifically say that
the arthur part was in 484 when it comes
when it's the dark ages in the beginning
it's 484 and then it says 1600 years
later which would mean that the movie
takes place in 2084 and I don't says
that ah that mean the Transformers takes
place in the future I don't ha
Cody was just whispering to himself the
whole time I think I literally Haram
stat1 point so here's the thing so it's
not even like because I was sitting
there for a lot of the movie we talked
about this to the kids movies and stuff
to ours being that through a lot of
movie and I was like okay mmm obviously
there's an audience for this the a clock
was sold out which but there were a
bunch people around I'm like right baby
you know there was there were people
laughing it really dumb jokes and I like
short okay you know what people like
Jeff Dunham you know there's an audience
for everything sure okay maybe this is
just not for us
right right in the final in the final
scene people are just least big in
droves like half the theater got up
before the credit started to roll the
Optimus Prime was doing his last speech
you're go it's the world and all reshape
didn't my name is Optimus Prime and
people are like just leaving in like
groups I don't it's gonna be okay I
laugh at how many times Optimus Prime
referred to his own name that was like
oh my like agent Lee while he's fighting
people he's just constantly telling them
what it's like he's like back and it
goes like say my name say my name I give
this negative 3/5 asia's Prime's out of
23 Optimus trends
that your rating mmm-hmm I give it zero
negative thank you it is not more than
meets the eye it is exactly what we see
I literally your tag and it is exactly
as it seemed it is yeah it is yeah yeah
there's no there's no mysticism there's
no surprise though there was no shock
and with everything that happened we
were saying this in the car there's no
struggle no one is lost like there's no
sense of loss you're in a giant war with
giant aliens no one's gonna die not one
person that we care about is gonna die
oh that was my other favorite thing what
they were talking about how the world
was going to basically be destroyed and
they were like tens of millions of
people will die and it's like um that's
not a lot of people in the grand scheme
of the earth well that's less than
America um all right next somebody gets
despicable three I think possibly maybe
Cody's gonna go die now like you're
gonna cry though I couldn't drag
internally like since that place of the
movie I'm gonna go home and watch the
fate of the Furious bye
[Music]
you